if there's any human experience more
Universal than love its loss and that's
the exact flavor of optimism explored in
Pet Sematary plus horror and creepy
masks and cats Pet Sematary open to
relatively good reviews largely due to a
few key themes and moments of crucial
character development but as the ending
swirled and the gory mayhem you might
have lost track of those themes let's
dig in and resurrect the ending of Pet
Sematary spoilers ahead the film's
protagonist Lewis Creed is shown to be
blunt and realistic for him sugarcoating
things like dead cats is an unhealthy
approach to parenting perfectly natural
just like been his natural this
rationalism is what makes Lewis's
decision to upset the natural balance so
surprising despite the fact that he
already watched his undead cat church go
totally bonkers Lewis abandons common
sense it tries to reincarnate his
daughter
initially Lewis achieves his goal and
Ellie is raised from the dead and
returns home even though Lewis makes a
costly mistake in his decision to spend
more time with his daughter he does come
full circle and regain a degree of
level-headedness in his final moments as
he fights with his daughter he decides
to take Judds advice about dead being
better making the painful decision to
rien delis life le inarguably goes
through the most change throughout the
course of the movie she starts out as a
curious friendly eight-year-old who
loves her cat and enjoys the company of
her new friend and neighbor that changes
when Church comes back from the dead and
starts acting like hell's grumpy cat
Elly begins to feel isolated and asks
her father if they can move back to
Boston but the real changes come during
her ninth birthday party when she dies
that's a pretty big change Elly is
resurrected by her father and nothing is
ever the same again now Elly makes it
her mission to kill all those around her
so she can resurrect her family as she
carries out her nefarious plans she
displays an impressive array of
abilities she seems to be able to
channel the spirits of others who have
died she does this once with the spirit
of Judds wife and once with her late
aunt spirit despite all this Elly is
able to accomplish her goal of feeling
secure in her family by the end of the
film it was a happy ending Pet Sematary
places a heavy focus on death and the
emotions associated with it throughout
its run time the film manages to explore
all of the five stages of grief denial
anger bargaining depression and
acceptance Lewis can't accept that his
daughter is gone forever
and decides to resurrect her showcasing
classic denial when Rachel talks about
her sister she starts to tell Lewis that
if she had only brought her sister her
meal in person that things would be
different at this point Rachel shows
that she's stuck in the bargaining stage
of grief however once she's confronted
with an undead daughter trying to kill
herself engage her demeanor is much more
in line with an angry form of grief
Judd seems to be in a stage of
acceptance saying that what is dead is
best left dead by the time the Crede
family meets him of course it's strongly
implied that he tried to bring his own
wife back then dealt with the
consequences putting down your zombie
wife is one surefire way to accept loss
from the abusive mother in Carrie to the
Reverend and revival religion as a
common theme in Stephen King's works and
the 2019 adaptation of Pet Sematary is
no different at the beginning of the
film Lewis and Rachel are shown to have
theological differences when they have a
brief disagreement about the existence
of an afterlife later after Elly is
brought back to life she mentions when
she was dead she'd been to a hell-like
afterlife and says that heaven does not
exist additionally when Elly first
returns she describes dying as
everything went black and later says
that she never wanted to be brought back
to life an odd statement for someone
supposedly suffering in hell
it's not so big want to give you besides
the discussion of an afterlife some
could claim the name of the family cat
is a signifier of Stephen King's views
and organized religion the first evil
domino that falls is the insistence on
keeping Church a part of the family
get it Lewis may have revived his lost
daughter but the ritual doesn't come
without a heavy price very quickly
Ellie's behavior turns violent and it
becomes apparent that the girl who
returned may look like Ellie but the
cheery lovable child she once was is now
gone Pet Sematary is abundantly clear in
its message the laws of nature should
not be broken because Lewis is unable to
accept the loss of his daughter
everything begins to spiral out of
control he is so focused on his grief
that he forgets the simple fact that she
can never truly return had he come to
terms with his loss he and his family
would have been able to cope eventually
instead the inability to face reality
leads to destruction in Stephen King's
novel the Wendigo plays a largely
important role in the overall narrative
the Wendigo is an evil spirit that
brings the dead back to life and then
possesses the body of the reincarnated
person it's also the Windigo that lures
those suffering from grief to the burial
ground prompting them to return their
loved ones to life in an interview with
slash film when asked if the Wendigo was
originally planned to be shown in the
film screenwriter Jeff Bueller replied
there isn't anything you could think of
that we didn't try once it's strongly
hinted that the Wendigo is the cause of
the magical resurrections going on those
woods
belong to something else although
ambiguous in their origin several
animalistic cries are heard coming from
the woods throughout the film and it is
heavily implied that at least some of
these are made by the Wendigo with many
horror films that gain even some
financial success Studios tend to expand
on those titles and create new series
with multiple entries with that in mind
there's no reason why studio heads
wouldn't want to see another Pet
Sematary movie if this one does well at
the box office the only thing getting in
the way of that plan the films rather
resolute ending le resurrects her mother
they kill and bring back Lewis and then
all three undead family members go after
gage getting around this obstacle is
something that the film's producer
Lorenzo de vana Ventura has discussed in
interviews according to de Bona Ventura
there may be room to make more Pet
Sematary films in the form of prequels
there are a lot of stories that could be
explored in the town local legends to
the sinister Wendigo itself the town of
Ludlow is filled with more than enough
history to supply filmmakers with
interesting material to make a prequel
at the very least or maybe they could
dig into those creepy kids in the masks
what kit does that check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]